bogota is a big
dirty and noisy city air pollution kills
about 2 000 people here every year
the air quality in the colombian capital
is often so bad
that an environmental state of emergency
has to be declared
greenhouse gas emissions linked to the
transporting of goods by road
contributes significantly to the problem
but that is sent to change in part
thanks to people such as daniel sanchez
he used to be part of the problem now
he's part of the solution
a pioneer of change on the streets of
bogota
i used to drive a truck there were
always two of us
everything took a long time because the
traffic jams and having to look for a
place to park
it was really tiring
now he drives an electric delivery
tricycle
this is the cross docking station at the
edge of the city center
goods are transferred here from large
trucks to the small eco-friendly
vehicles for delivery into downtown
the project was launched by the
municipality since last year the green
alliance has headed the city government
for the first time
transport is responsible for about 79 to
particulate emissions here
and 39 of that amount results from
transporting goods by road
by switching to these new vehicles we
can cut emissions by 16 metric tons a
day
so the impact will be huge
the world bank has made 300 000
available to the project
it's still early days during the current
pilot phase
the fleet of small electric delivery
vehicles numbers just
15.
they're the work of a startup in
medellin
but the model designed for that city
needs to be adapted to conditions in
bogota
the logistics are very different from
medellin
retailers aren't concentrated in one
district
distances are much larger so the wear
and tear on the electric components is
greater
we need to innovate and start working on
improving the motor and the battery
so we can provide the companies in the
project with an efficient solution
the lolla cargo tricycles can carry one
cubic meter of goods
that's about 1 8 the volume of a
standard delivery truck
daniel sanchez's destinations today are
small shops and pharmacies
he works on commission so for him time
is money
and he zips from one customer to the
next
he maneuvers his electric bike through
traffic jams
he's glad to be rid of his truck
traffic it's just the best thing
i can go bike lanes and sidewalks
anywhere
and i can take shortcuts
i can get to any point really fast
it's much better than before
not being stuck in traffic not having to
look for a parking place
makes delivering goods more efficient
several companies have signed up to the
project they not only want to cut their
harmful emissions but also save time and
money doing so
nutresa is a major manufacturer of
processed and convenient
foods it's an ideal candidate for taking
part in the pilot phase of the project
in colombia most of its products are
sold in small corner shops
and by street vendors
the pilot phase has been running for
just one month
but the results are already very
significant and very positive
six other companies in the city have
also joined the project
and i hope many more will too
using sustainable methods of transport
has many advantages
for people's quality of life the
environment
and the development of urban logistics
it's too soon to evaluate the pilot
project as a whole
but daniel sanchez for one hopes it will
prove a success
and set a precedent he says his work
days are a third
shorter now and his earnings higher he
also enjoys the attention
passers-by are fascinated
about people ask me is that your bike
and i say
sadly no it's not
they find it really cool and think it's
a good idea no exhaust
nothing that harms the environment i
feel i'm promoting change
he still takes the bus home but he's
saving up to buy a good bike
and then he will contribute even more to
the greening of bogota
you